back in october rush limbaugh opened up
about his faith i mentioned at the
outset of this and the first day i told
you that i have a
personal relationship with jesus christ
it is
of immense
value strength confidence
and that's why i'm able to remain fully
committed
to the idea that what is supposed to
happen will happen
when it's meant to rush was convinced
that what is supposed to happen
would happen when it was meant to and
as always with impeccable timing ever
the showman
probably with an assist from the big guy
upstairs
you would say rush limbaugh died
on ash wednesday the very day that we
are told to remember
remember man that thou art dust and unto
dust
thou shalt return a special providence
in a death on ash wednesday now we can
all pray
that rush is enjoying the greatest show
imaginable
before the very face of god i'm michael
knowles and this is the michael knowles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
show
back to the show you know things are
pretty crazy these days
probably a good time to consider
investing in gold
the price of gold has been skyrocketing
lately
and you know i've mentioned before that
i've enjoyed investing in precious
metals
but i think sometimes people think i've
certainly thought this
it's very difficult to invest in
physical gold because i don't happen to
have zillions of dollars lying around
you know
a bar of gold costs a lot of money acre
gold
has figured out how to let you invest in
physical gold
without shelling out a ton of cash at
once they will let you subscribe
to gold bars for as little as thirty
dollars per month
that's right now thirty dollars is not
going to buy you a gold bar
not going to buy you a ton of gold but
once your gold stash
hits the limit acre will then ship you
discreetly
the physical gold to your door i think
this is an ingenious way
to start investing in physical gold and
i really really do
enjoy investing in physical precious
metals they've got their 100
a month subscription to a 5 gram gold
bar
acre is crafting a solid gold 24 karat
999.99 millimeter bullet
for you to buy right now how cool is
that i i do have to say this
you can't shoot the bullet unless you're
aiming at a werewolf then you you
absolutely can but otherwise you don't
you shouldn't shoot the bullet
uh it's very very cool though i love
this thing can't wait to get one
visit getacregold.com michael start
investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient and
mention
at get underscore acre that is get acre
gold
dot com slash michael thank you
aker gold for supporting the show rush
limbaugh
is not is not possible to overstate
russia's influence and what you're going
to hear over the next few days
as everyone is processing their grief
let me rephrase that
as conservatives are processing their
grief over the death of rush
and as left wingers are
doing quite the opposite and we'll get
to that in just a bit
you're going to hear that rush limbaugh
was so important he was the central
figure to talk radio that's true
that rush limbaugh saved am radio that's
true that rush limbaugh gave
conservatives a voice when they were
losing their voice that's true
that rush limbaugh is responsible really
for all of the alternative conservative
media that
you know i'm engaging in right now not
not just on radio but in podcast
daily wire you know so on and so forth
that's all true as well
what rush does not get enough credit for
he gets some credit for but he doesn't
get enough credit for it
is that rush limbaugh was
a prime representative the
probably representative of the
conservative
movement of the real conservative
movement you know we spend a lot of time
on this show
talking about what it means to be a
conservative what it means to be a right
winger
what it means to be a left-winger in
american politics you know with
with respect to the other side of
politics obviously i'm coming at this
thing
from the right of attila the hun but
we're trying to figure out what exactly
does this mean
and now you're going to see a lot of a
lot of praise for rush
but for much of his career the
establishment right did not want to
associate with him
now you always had the people that i
consider to be the real conservative
leaders
up to and including people like william
f buckley jr many other people
loved rush would uh you know bring rush
into their circles
love to associate with rush but a lot of
the very fancy conservatives at the very
fancy think tanks and the very fancy
sort of cinecure positions they they
felt rush was a little beneath them
i i sometimes think they treated him as
uh
as a bit of a sideshow you know i'm not
going to go into naming names but you
had people who were a little more
establishment
really did not want to associate with
rush very much and yet
wise people of all different stripes all
colors
all sorts all occupations all
socioeconomic
levels wise people of all those sorts in
my experience
have really truly appreciated
and admired rush limbaugh i'm talking
about
your average joe on the street i'm
talking about truck drivers
i'm talking about professors and priests
i'm talking about the whole
gamut of human experience i've truly
i've talked to people
who have really no better than like a
9th or 10th grade education
who say rush limbaugh was a genius i've
talked to people
who have multiple advanced degrees phds
that sort of thing
who use the exact same words rush
limbaugh was a genius there was
no better forget just broadcaster that
true too
but there was no better political
analyst
and commentator in his entire era
than rush limbaugh you know when i we
moved to nashville
whatever it was a few months ago and i
was supposed to move
a week early but then i got a phone call
from the eib network
asking if i would like to fill in for
the rush limbaugh show nothing
could have possibly gotten me to delay
my moving
to nashville at the time i've got a
pregnant wife the whole daily wire
company is moving to nashville
they're setting up my studio there i no
longer had a studio
back in los angeles they were actually
tearing it down there was
one thing that could have gotten me to
stay in la
so that i could go to the rush limbaugh
studio and fill in
that of course what was sitting behind
the golden eib microphone
i uh i i've publicly you know thank to
russia and the whole eib team
many times for that honor and i
considered it such an honor not just
because
rush limbaugh was the biggest deal in
all of broadcasting
but because i so respected the man
and his understanding of politics and
his role
in american politics i think there are
going to be a lot of establishment types
who are going to try to sideline what
russia stood for the people who admired
rush right now
we cannot let them do it the new york
times understood
that rush limbaugh for all intents and
purposes was the conservative movement
with all the jokes and all the sort of
vision the all of the sort of grander
vision all the way up to his faith that
we were discussing
all the way down the new york times
understood this that's why they attacked
him
so much i i i'm so sorry that he's gone
but i'm so pleased that if he had to go
he would he would go on ash wednesday i
had a priest once
in los angeles who was ill
and we knew you know it wasn't he wasn't
going to be around forever and he
he prayed that he would die on ash
wednesday that there was this sort of
poetic real beauty to dying on ash
wednesday
this day when we are to contemplate our
mortality and rush clearly did that not
just because he got sick
but he was thinking about his faith for
a long time
and he he faced it with such courage
because i think he had a vision
of the life beyond new york times
not quite as effusive in their praise of
rush limbaugh
i was hesitating even to read the
negative comments about rush
but i just you know from a distance i
just have this sort of
suspicion that he might have gotten a
kick out of it you can tell a man by his
enemies and rush at all the right
enemies
new york times headline rush limbaugh
dies at 70. turned
talk radio into a right-wing attack
machine
is that what he did just a few choice
quotes from the new york times obit
with a following of 15 million and a
divisive style of mockery
grievance and denigrating language he
was a force
in reshaping american conservatism
that's true
how divisive the most popular radio host
in america new york times
runs a hit piece as their obit they
accuse him of being divisive they accuse
him of mocking people they accuse him of
grievance and denigration denigrating
language okay
new york times he became a singular
figure in the american media fomenting
mistrust
grievances and even hatred on the right
for americans who did not share his or
his followers views
pause for a moment nobody
in this country has done more to foment
distrust
and disdain for the american left
than the new york times nobody you
maybe they want to blame rush limbaugh
no the lies
the distortions the libel that that was
all the times rush limbaugh
called attention to it but that was that
was all the times that did he just
didn't let them get away with it
he pushed baseless claims and toxic
rumors
long before twitter and reddit became
havens for such disinformation pay
attention to this because
what they're saying is look you all now
we're talking about how terrible red it
is and all social media and we've got to
regulate it and kick all the
the conservatives off of it right and
that's they're pretending
in a way that this is a unique evil
we've got to
come in and censor these apps actually
new york times is after
a new app right now they're trying to
censor it they're shocked that free
speech is going up
but but they're kind of showing their
hand a little bit here because they're
saying no it's not just new
it's not just trump it's not just the
neo-nazis and
whatever silly terms they want to call
conservatives today
they say rush did this decades ago oh
oh it's the same old story same story
different day
the same people who were trying to shut
up conservatives
40 years ago trying to do the same thing
now and they're trying to pretend that
it's new
and then this this paragraph was really
something else
to detractors he was a sanctimonious
charlatan
the most dangerous man in america a
label he co-opted
and some critics insisted that he had no
real political power
only an intimidating self-aggrandizing
presence that swayed an
aging ultra-right fringe whose numbers
while impressive
were not considered great enough to
affect the outcome of national elections
but then they don't say anything about
his admirers so they say you know
to his detractors he was this ordinarily
if you would use that phrase you would
say and to his admirers no new york
times won't even do that i mean they go
on they
they attack his appearance they attack
all sorts of things i
say well done rush well done
oh my goodness if i could ever earn
the scorn from these derelicts and
degenerates at the new york times that
rush limbaugh earned
oh my goodness gracious i would feel
that i had really accomplished something
i would be so that is something really
to be proud of i know
pride deadly sin queen of all sins
don't don't want to think about that
sort of thing but i would fee
i would take great comfort if i were
rush limbo and if i were russia's family
in the unmitigated
disdain with not even with a pretense of
trying to be polite or civilized about
it
just the the vicious way that the left
is going after him right now
that's a badge of honor you know
when lots of enemies on the internet are
trying to get your information you've
got to protect yourself
nobody is coming after your identity
right nobody's coming after your data i
know i used to think that once i don't
think that anymore
if you think that think again give me
just one example there's a text message
scam going on
claiming to give away a free year of
netflix ooh i like free stuff that's
great right
if you receive a text message like that
do not respond or click the link
it is a scammer trying to get you to log
into a fake website
to steal your personal information and
credit card number it's very important
to understand how
credit card theft how cyber crime how
identity theft how
all these sorts of things are affecting
our lives every day we put our
information
at risk on the internet in an instant a
cyber criminal could harm what's yours
your finances
your credit your reputation good thing
there's lifelock
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock identity theft protection
join now and save up to 25 off your
first year
at lifelock.com slash knowles k-w-l-e-s
head on over right now protect your
identity an
ounce of prevention seriously is worth a
pound of cure here lifelock dot com
slash knowles canada wlas for 25 off
the new york times is not the only
outlet celebrating the death of rush
limbaugh
we're hearing this from all sorts of
blue check marks all over twitter and
all various fields
and it it proves it is proven true again
and again the more and more of these
that you
read that a man can be judged by his
enemies
my absolute favorite one is from
somebody named charlotte climber
charlotte climber is an individual who
has a lot of followers on social media
and
makes a big show on these platforms i'll
tell you more about charlotte at the end
just take a listen
rush limbaugh was a coward and white
supremacist
he aggressively and cynically exploited
divisions in our country
by weaponizing hatred and bigotry for
his own personal gain
charlotte sounds really loving huh not
at all
full of hatred or bigotry no really
loving then
here's the money line if rush limbaugh
deserves credit for anything it is
his pioneering work in spreading
disinformation
and directly enabling our nation's
current state of vast distrust of
experts
and spurning of good faith in the public
discourse he will not be missed by
rational adults
now what you need to know to really
appreciate this attack on rush limbaugh
this this attack that rush was known for
spreading
disinformation for
taking away people's trust in experts
for spurning good faith discourse
charlotte
climber is a man who pretends to be a
woman
and moreover he is the communications
director
for the pro-abortion group catholics for
choice which is a contradiction in terms
it is not possible to be
a catholic it is not permissible to be a
catholic
and support abortion the church does not
permit that
catholics for abortion is
not it is a contradiction
you can't have it he
a man whose entire public persona
is deception is a lie
attacks rush for spreading
disinformation
and you know there are many experts out
there who say that men can be women and
women can be men there are many experts
out there
who say that catholics can support
abortion
can disregard the church's 2000 year
teaching on this issue
the experts would be wrong probably good
to distrust those if those are the
experts then i'm glad
we are not trusting those experts
spurning of good faith in public
discourse says someone
pushing lies and deception we will not
be missed by rational adults show me the
rational adult
i'm looking around i don't see very many
beyond
mr climber we have cameron caskey who
is sort of the lesser known of the david
hogg people you know of the
of the young gun control people
cameron caskey tweeted out quote
rush limbaugh has passed on but worry
not
his memory lives on through bigots
everywhere
that's right now i mentioned cameron's
not because he's particularly well known
but because i think he's actually
revealing something about these people
who are attacking rush
namely it's not about rush
just like just like the attacks on trump
we're not really about trump
the stomping you know dancing on
russia's grave is not really about rush
it's about the people that rush spoke to
and what that means is it's about the
conservative movement
rush limbaugh had an audience of uh i
think 25 million
something like that it's a lot of people
this fellow kamkasky says that all those
people are bigots
you know people who admired rush are
bigots
this gets to what we've been hearing
since the election 75 million americans
they don't just disagree with you they
don't just happen to be conservative
they are
nazi white supremacists they need to be
censored silenced and ostracized from
society
there are going to be some squishes who
call themselves conservatives but
but not that kind of conservative you
know i'm a really serious intellectual
elite reasonable conservative i'm
not like those rush limbaugh
conservatives
for i don't think that all they're
sucking up and bootlicking to the
left is going to keep them out of the
gulags but neither here nor there i
don't i'm not really concerned about
how those people live their lives it's
really for the rest of the conservatives
out there to remember
this is all about you rush took a lot of
the brunt of it he's taking some of the
brunt of it now
but this is about you beyond these sort
of silly people mouthing off on twitter
you get another silly person mouthing
off on twitter but he's got a big
credential
scott shapiro no relation
i hope i don't think so to my colleague
ben
he's a professor at yale law school this
is the top law school in the country
do you know what he writes on twitter he
says i wouldn't say
i was happy that rush limbaugh died it's
more like euphoria
that's not just some edgy tweeter
you know some guy with a tv show or a
podcast or a radio show or something no
that's a
that's a law professor at what is
considered to be the most prestigious
law school in the entire country saying
i was euphoric
first of all that i was euphoric that a
man died second of all that i was
euphoric that a countryman
fellow countryman died and third of all
he was euphoric because of what because
of russia's political views it's not
because of the cut of russia's jib
not because of his beard not because of
the polo shirts he wore
it's because he's a conservative what
does scott shapiro think about his
students
what is scott shapiro what do so many of
these guys
think about all the rest of us
trump and rush in in many you know in
many ways very different they approached
politics
from a different angle you know russia's
approach to politics was probably more
systematic
it was more rooted in
political philosophy more rooted in
political history
trump it was all gut right it was he
came he comes from the world of business
he didn't come from the world of
politics
but in many ways these guys were
kindred spirits and trump recognized
this
and he made his first appearance
on a network show since he left the
white house
to call in to a tv network
and pay tribute to rush three or four
days ago i'd call him just to find out
you know his fight was very very
courageous and
he was very very sick and you know from
diagnosis on it was just something that
was not going to be beaten but
you wouldn't know it and he is married
to an incredible woman catherine who
really every time i spoke to him he he
would tell me
how great she was she took such great
care he was very brave i mean he
in theory could have been gone four
months ago really
he just he was fighting till the very
end he was a fighter
a really touching tribute from president
trump you know president trump is sort
of known for his off-the-cuff remarks
and
sometimes he says things that are not
totally politic i remember
when he was posthumously awarding i
guess it was the medal of freedom to
antonin scalia
you know he clearly didn't know terribly
much about scalia so he's kind of
reading it
in the moment he says and scalia
survived by his wife and his 10 kids 10
kids wow oh man i knew i liked that guy
you guys were busy huh
is that one of my favorite trump lines
uh but
probably not appropriate if you're
eulogizing somebody or something like
that
and here what does trump say goes i
called the guy who was such a fighter he
so loved his country
uh really i'm really pleased that uh
former president
did that called in to pay tribute to him
he gave him such a such a wonderful
honor at the state of the union when he
he awarded rush the medal of freedom in
that room and i'm
i'm so glad he did because it drove the
democrats crazy
i bet it drove some republicans crazy
and most of all because
rush deserved it that's a great use of
the term or of the
the medal of freedom guys like
donald trump and rush limbaugh are much
much much more representative of
true conservatism whatever you want to
call that it's a term that's often
invoked
by liberal rats like the lincoln project
we're the true conservatives now give us
money so we can elect democrats
uh but it's it's invoked by those guys
but there is a sort of
truer or deeper more substantive
conservatism
in america and trump and rush are much
more representative of that
then basically all of the think tankers
and the talkers and the politicians
who call themselves right wing put
together with some exception
but basically put together and the way
you can tell
is if you look at the way that the left
goes after them not even in just one
isolated moment because one or two
things
but year after year as their influence
grows and grows
they attack them and they attack them
and they attack them
when the golden eib microphone goes
silent
as it has it's uh you know i i suspect
it's not so sad for rush i suspect he's
at his eternal reward and we can pray
that that's the case
uh very sad for those of us who will
miss him because it's not just his voice
that is disappearing from the country
but he was a spokesman for so many of us
and the left could never crack him you
know they really
never managed to they tried so many
times but they are going to try to do
that now
and the censorship that is going to that
is already going on
against the people rush spoke for that
is going to increase
dramatically one way to fight back
against this left-wing censorship
support organizations
such as prageru you know how much i love
prager you prageru
is leading the charge against big tech
censorship fighting for our voices to be
heard for and what you know prager you
very well if you're listening to this
show
because i have appeared in many prageru
videos
a lot of us here at daily wire have
appeared in lots of prageru videos
we've written on prageru videos i
actually host a show at prageru
called the book club which i highly
recommend you check out if you have not
started listening to that already it's
just terrific
the america that we love is slipping
away and i for one don't want to let
the left win a victory after cultural
victory
so i think we got to do something about
it you got to support prageru their
videos are watched 4 million times every
single day
more than 70 percent of viewers say
their minds were changed after watching
more than 60 percent of those viewers
are young prageru's on the front lines
they need
you to help supply the resources
to continue this fight if you want to be
sure that your donation dollars
will be used to support values that you
support
yourself donate to prageru at prageru
prageru.com
dailywire that is prageru.com dailywire
also go on over and support the daily
wire we've got a lot of very
exciting stuff going on right now we're
getting into the culture we're not just
commenting on the culture anymore or
criticizing the culture anymore we were
going out we were actively making
cultural products disney tried to cancel
gina carano the other day
star of the mandalorian well we we hired
her now she's my new colleague never
thought i'd
be colleagues with an mma fighter and
disney star but
strange things have happened in 2020 and
2021. we're also going to have backstage
live that's going to be
february 23rd for the state of the union
make sure you go subscribe
for that head on over to dailywire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
welcome back to the show the
silencing of the golden eib microphone
the rush limbaugh show
is going to cause an increase in the
censorship
regime that was already going on because
rush spoke for a lot of people
who did not have the ability to speak on
a large platform for themselves
the new york times is already expressing
this desire of the left-wing
establishment
to shut up ordinary people
new york times has a headline
about this new app clubhouse a clubhouse
hasn't been around that long i'm on the
app i haven't used it very much it's
kind of nice though you
you basically join into these different
groups and it's audio based it's not
text based
so on twitter you know everyone says
really mean things because they're all
behind a computer screen they
you know it's a sort of a an alienating
process when you're communicating only
through words
you don't have to hear the inflection in
someone's voice you don't need to see
the look on their face so people
tend to be pretty mean on twitter i find
people aren't that mean on clubhouse
because it's audio based however
it would appear that this free-flowing
conversation that's going on in
clubhouse
is uh too much for the left to handle
new york times tweets out quote
unfettered conversations are taking
place on clubhouse
an invitation-only app that lets people
gather in audio chat rooms
the app has exploded in popularity
despite grappling with concerns over
harassment
misinformation and privacy concerns
whose concerns
sounds like the concerns of the new york
times they're worried about
unfettered conversations
think about the state of american
journalism specifically of american
liberal journalism
that conversations might be unfettered
you know i'm a conservative i actually
do think some things are out of bounds
i i'm with the founding fathers on this
topic i think
things like uh fraud obscenity
so maybe we should have some regulations
on those i am not as has become a sort
of very popular phrase in the last
i don't know three or four years a free
speech absolutist i'm not
i'm a i'm an absolutist for free speech
in the american tradition and those are
different things
i support the american tradition
of free speech which i think is fabulous
but i don't believe there's any such
thing
as totally absolute free speech this is
a finite world
and we're not going to permit things
like fraud
like threats like you know so on and so
forth but the liberals have always said
we're for free speech they're the free
speech movement at berkeley to destroy
all the old
social norms in this country they insist
that burning the american flag is
absolutely 100 protected free speech no
matter what the american legal tradition
said before
they brought this to the supreme court
but now the liberals are showing their
hands they're saying no we don't
unfettered conversations no way buddy
we're the the speech police we're the
ones who are supposed to tell you
what you're allowed to say they tried to
shut down rush limbaugh
they obviously tried to shut down donald
trump they said this is too much
two you you're not allowed to say those
sorts of things you're only allowed to
say well we want you to say
and do what we want you to do another
person another
liberal elite that typifies this point
of view
bill gates now i'm not one for bill
gates conspiracy theories you know there
have been a lot of bill gates conspiracy
theories
for instance some people say that bill
gates wants to kill
babies in africa i'm not one for
conspiracy theories
i'm one for listening to what bill gates
says and then
when i hear his own words i believe him
when he describes his own views
one goal that he describes of course is
that he wants to kill babies in africa
he wants to increase abortion in africa
he wants to increase
the use of contraception he wants to
curb the growth
specifically of africa and the third
world but he's very concerned about
overpopulation which is a discredited
and preposterous
and anti-human and wicked sort of
concept to be worried about
he says that you know that's not a
conspiracy theory he talks about that
openly as do many liberal elites
so i don't like this guy generally i
don't like him
because i think his moral vision is
wrong and perverse
and maybe you know he came to it
honestly maybe it's you know it's an
honest mistake we all
we're all uh seeing him imperfectly
so i hope that he turns it around i hope
that he changes his mind repents that
sort of thing
but as of now this guy is
a perfect encapsulation of the elite
liberal view and as such
he says very terrible things and one of
those
very terrible things you might think
it's trivial but i actually don't think
it is
he wants to take away your beef
he does i know this sounds like a bill
gates conspiracy theory
bill gates wants to take away your
hamburger he does he just said that
he said that he wants to take away your
beef he said quote
i don't think the poorest 80 countries
will be eating synthetic beef
i do think all rich countries should
move
to 100 synthetic beef
so he's saying poor countries they're
not going to be able to afford synthetic
beef but rich countries can
meaning fake meat that's grown in a lab
somewhere
and not only can they do that but they
should do that why should
they do that i don't know because bill
gates well he's a sales genius and was
able to sell a lot of computers in the
90s
is a moral idiot i mean there's he has
no
there's no reason to believe that bill
gates has any sort of sophisticated
understanding of philosophy
ethics morality theology
he's just sort of saying stuff but
because he's really rich
and full of himself he believes that he
is capable of pontificating on these
sorts of subjects that he knows nothing
about
why should they move to synthetic beef
well
because this i'm just guessing here
because you know it's bad to kill the
animals why is it bad to kill the
animals i don't know they never seem to
explain that
and because you know the methane from
the cows it's going to
cause global warming what's global
warming is that really going to kill us
all maybe when's it going to kill us 12
years 18 months
is it going to kill us before global
cooling kills us in the 1970s is it
going to kill us before
the essentially moderate weather that's
happened since the late 1990s
is that gonna i don't know they never
explain it but it is going to kill us
that's why we got to switch
to synthetic beef and bill gates adds
quote
you can get used to the taste difference
and the claim is
they're going to make it taste even
better over time oh good the fake meat's
going to taste better over time
and you can get used to it you can get
used to it
so do it you have to now
you'll notice he's using these terms
here you know they should do this they
should do that
but more than he uses those kinds of
terms
he uses the terms of inevitability he'll
say this
will happen this won't happen
because for bill gates like all
progressives
he believes that the he understands the
science of history the science of
politics
and it's going to move in his direction
and if you don't like that
well that's too bad oh you got your
little constitution your little
self-government well
too bad buddy because i know the way the
future is going to move
and it's going to take your hamburger
away and there's nothing you can do
about it
bill gates expresses the same view on
jobs
and energy you know the left wingers
like bill gates and other liberal elites
have decided that they're going to take
away jobs in the energy sector
joe biden promised he wouldn't do it but
at other times he promised he would do
it we all knew he was going to do it now
he's done it
he's taken away jobs in the fossil fuel
industry for instance
so bill gates was on a tv show he was
asked
hey what do you say to the millions of
people who are losing their jobs in the
energy industry
bill gates has soft consolation for them
what happens to the 2.8
million americans that are working in
the oil and gas industry
this is a 30-year transition and there's
lots of
clean jobs that can be uh created in
those same locations a total number of
jobs will actually
go up there may be some places there's
dislocation and so as we budget
we have to think about those affected
communities
as well as funding the innovation and
deployment
who the hell is we who is we as we
decide how we're going to
take away millions of jobs and we decide
what was the we
bill does bill think he's speaking for
the american people of course not
the american people don't want to take
away millions of energy jobs
that's why joe biden had to lie to them
before the election and say i'm not
going to go after fracking i'm not going
to go after
fossil fuels and then what does he do he
immediately goes after them
which those of us who had been listening
for a while we all knew that but the
fact that he lied shows that's not
popular so who is we
bill we i think are these self-appointed
benevolent bettors the liberal elites
who are going to usher in the new age
and there's just
nothing you can do about it yes well
there's going to be some displacement
but well you know but it's a 30-year
transition
what 30-year transition i didn't sign up
for any 30-year transition
and i didn't appoint bill freaking gates
to utterly transform the american energy
sector over 30 years when did i vote for
that
when did anybody vote for that
none of us did but this is the way the
blob works and
when i talk about the blob or the
liberal elite i'm talking about
the dominant regime that i guess right
now expresses itself through the elected
politicians because democrats have
unified government
it expresses itself through the
administrative state the bureaucracy
it expresses itself through the
universities
through technology and generally
speaking with some exceptions through
the richest americans
isn't that weird you remember how the
republicans are supposed to be the fat
cat party of the billionaires well how
come
most of the richest people in america
are democrats isn't that weird
doesn't that seem a little weird no not
really because the liberal
regime is the dominant regime it is the
power in america
it's where the power goes
this should not be normal by the
standard of
of the constitution not normal by the
standard of at least much of american
history not normal
by the standard of what we tell
ourselves about the way our society
works and our government works not
normal
but this is the new normal according to
many left wingers actually jen saki our
favorite current right
white house press secretary jen saki
admitted this she was asked a question
she said you know 15 days to slow the
spread
we're getting on a year now and there's
no end in sight to these lockdowns and
the masks and all this crazy nonsense
when is life going to get back to normal
jensaki shrugs her shoulders
this is the question as i'm sure is the
case for all of you that every neighbor
every friend every family member asks at
least
me in the street when i'm walking my dog
in the morning we want to be straight
with the american public though it is
we are not in a place where we can
predict exactly when everybody will feel
normal again and it has
there are a number of reasons one is
even though we will have
enough doses for every person in this
country as you all know because we've
talked about it in here
vaccine hesitancy remains a challenge uh
we need to ensure that that everybody
who
can get a dose is getting a dose we all
will also need to be masking for some
time
we will also need to be still taking
social distancing measures so
uh you know there there's of course is
an understandable question and i think
the president uh wants things to return
to normal as we all do
but we we don't know at this point what
that timeline is going to look like
the president does not want us to return
to normal because if he did he would
just do it because he has political
power because we
theoretically have self-government and
we theoretically elected this guy
president so if he wanted to he would
but he isn't
because he doesn't we
do not need to mask we do not need to
social distance an orwellian term if
ever there was one a contradiction in
terms
we do not need to do any of this silly
nonsense
we've had epidemics before many harsher
epidemics than
the coronavirus we haven't reordered
society in the way that these
psychos are reordering do you know how
we can return to normal
we can just stop listening to the
exalted dr fauci peace be upon him
the world leader you know we can just
stop listening to all of these
self-appointed
elites in all the dominant regime
unfortunately they have a lot of power
right now they have a lot of way of
lording that
over us gensake did this thing that is
so frustrating
you've probably experienced this if
you want someone to apologize to you and
the person they they can't quite
they know they should apologize but they
can't quite bring themselves to do it
so for instance they'll come to you and
they'll say hey i'm sorry if you feel
offended i'm sorry if you feel hurt
you say you don't apologize for my
feelings you can't control my feelings
you can control
what you did so apologize for what you
did or don't apologize for what you did
but don't give me this mishimo that's
what
jen saki is doing the question is when
can americans
expect to get back to normal we were
told 15 days to slow the spread
that seems like that was back in the i
don't know in the roosevelt
administration at this point seemed so
long ago
15 days to slow the spread when can we
expect to get back to normal
and she says well you know we just don't
know when people can feel normal again
don't tell me how i'm going to feel i
don't i don't i don't need you to worry
about how i'm going to feel
normal is not a feeling normal is
an objective reality
muzzling yourself with filthy cloth all
the time and not being able to see
people smiling faces
and having to not not be able to
understand what people are saying
that's not normal it's increasingly
becoming normal i'm sorry to say
but it's not normal not being able to
see your loved ones not being able to
bury your dead not being able to go
have weddings not being able to
celebrate thanksgiving and christmas
that's not normal it's increasingly
becoming normal because that's what
the liberal regime wants but that's what
we're asking when can we get back to
that and the answer jinsaki she's
getting better at evading questions
she sort of gave the answer here
when are we going to get back to that
normal the normal that we all consider
to be normal
we don't we don't get to do that
we will never get back to that if the
dominant liberal
regime is liberal elites
in all various industries up to and
including joe biden
if they get their way this is the new
normal seems pretty
abnormal to me i don't want you to think
that i am uh you know hyperbolic here
when i
say that the current rules that we're
living under the masks and the social
distancing whatever that means
that that you know this is a grave
threat to our way of life
maybe michael come on this will just be
a temporary measure
come on we're all in this together we're
together apart or whatever other creepy
contradictions they they want to make us
all spout
this is what the liberal regime prefers
there is a video that just came out
unfortunately there was a hidden camera
in some restaurant some bar
of an la health inspector la one of the
worst run cities for coronavirus and
also
they're not just the worst run in terms
of the spread of the virus but they're
also the worst run in terms of
the psychos who are enforcing rules
there this la health inspector
shows up shuts down this bar
and then as she's doing it she does a
little dance
you can see it through the security
footage
there she goes she's dancing around you
know
moving her hips shaking around
now i don't i don't want to read
too much into just this one video clip
it's pretty damning stuff
but maybe i don't know i don't know what
was going on in her head maybe she was
just maybe she's just a nut and she just
has to spontaneously start dancing in
public
if so you know not the best bedside
manner for a regulator who's
throwing people out of work but
i do know that normal is a choice
norms are a choice in many ways what
political correctness is what what
wokeness or you know whatever term you
want is is a new set of norms
actually i explore this topic in my
upcoming book which you can pre-order
right now speechless controlling words
controlling minds what
what political correctness does is
replaces the old moral norms
with new norms of speech so you're
replacing the standards and it's also
you're taking the focus from actions to
words
what what this woman did to go shut down
this business that was wrong of her to
do whether she danced or not
it's an arbitrary exercise of power it
should not be done right now and
i don't think any of us need to be
reminded that woman gets her paycheck
regardless this woman goes in shuts down
a place of business puts
workers out of their job probably puts
the owner
you know if this goes on long enough out
of his job
and she gets her paycheck and she gets
to dance on back down the street
back to her office what is joe biden
doing for businesses
i'm not talking big business which is
base in many ways not so different from
big government
conservatives are finally beginning to
wake up to that reality
what is joe biden doing for these small
businesses
poor gensake biden spokesman doesn't
have much of an answer
what is president biden doing for my
small business first and foremost he
nominated a woman to lead the small
business administration
stop stop right there please
this is sad but it's also very funny
it's it's sort of like you laugh or you
cry
with this sort of thing because they
don't have what is he doing for my small
business the answer is nothing
but the way the way that john jinsaki
expresses nothing is
what is jovan doing for my small
business he nominated a woman
to some post or whatever oh
cool can you answer my question please
i i truly could not
possibly care less the
the sex of the person that joe biden
nominated to some stupid bureaucratic
role
that's probably not going to do very
much for american business
i don't care that he nominated a woman i
don't care if a woman
is ever ever nominated
to whatever stupid bureaucratic post
they're talking about
i do care about the state of american
business i do care that people are
allowed
to run their businesses they're allowed
to
keep at least a little bit of what is
theirs that people are allowed to work
that people are allowed to go to these
restaurants and bars and go to these
businesses
that they can go out and have a
functioning society
how are you doing that joe biden ah we
don't really have an answer
i'm sorry i'm afraid we don't really
have an answer on that and frank you
know
i'm knocking jen saki because
she you know is not very good at her job
at being a spokesman
but she's really not much worse than joe
biden in many ways she's better than joe
biden joe biden just recently did a town
hall
and he managed to put his foot in his
mouth again
uh this this quote i think sums it all
up joe biden said
that uh everyone knows he he prefers
kids to people good to be back man
that's nice to see you sir
and you know you enjoy being home with a
baby more not only here that night too
yes
yeah he's nine and a half months so i'm
very happy no no everybody knows i like
kids better than people i saw a picture
of you with your grandson recently
that's right
so this is actually a very telling
comment
telling in many ways one joe is
obviously senile and not capable of
doing the job
and increasingly the biden
administration is empowering
kamala harris which is a story unto
itself
is joe not all there really what they're
really just empowering the bureaucrats
uh also that joe biden doesn't consider
kids people right if he's making a
distinction between kids and people
which would explain
his outrageous support for abortion
blasphemous support for abortion
given his protestations that he say in
his profession that he's a devout
catholic
but but of course if you don't consider
kids people then it makes a lot more
sense
but even on what he's saying here he
says you know i always like kids better
than people let's say he meant to say
adults or something
and anderson says oh i saw a picture of
you with your grandkid i saw you i read
a story about you playing video games
with your grandkid we covered that on
the show
joe biden doesn't like kids better than
adults i think you know who i think
might disagree with the claim that joe
biden really really likes kids
his grandchild that he refuses to
acknowledge
this story i can't believe that people
haven't given this more
air time i can believe it with the
mainstream media but now with
conservatives
joe biden has a grandchild that was uh
conceived and born out of wedlock
and he refuses to acknowledge the
grandchild that's very callous that's
very cruel
that not such a great guy not such a
great guy
you know who was a great guy rush
limbaugh that's who and uh i'm i'm very
sad
that he's gone but it seems
we see a little glimmer of the
providence in the way that rush went
in the in all that we get to have taken
from his life
and career uh we'll be praying for him
we'll be praying for the country i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show rush limbaugh passes
away and the online left celebrates the
biden administration has
literally no idea what the hell they are
talking about when it comes to reopening
schools and we learn from the washington
post
that spraying gorilla glue in your hair
is yet another legacy of systemic racism
that's today on the ben shapiro show
give it a listen